je suis ton père
[Musique]
on est sur le scande la frenchie est con
d'eric maxim et là on a vu japan fois
maximum et si ça va très bien
est ce que tu peux nous expliquer pour
ceux qui ne le sauraient pas encore
aujourd'hui puisque fait ce que vous
faites
il ya en connais plein de moments là
c'est comme ça ce que vous faites à
l'ifa qu'à l'évacuation et puis surtout
ils m'ont présenté un peu des start up
pour qu'on voie un peu bas qui elles
sont ce qu'elles fonctionnent tout ça
quoi
mais en fait c'est très passé de la
french tech ça regroupe les startups des
nouvelles technologies issues d'une même
entité comme ça partout où tu vas dans
le monde tu vois le logo de la fiche
take two sais que tu vas faire une start
up innovantes et française évidemment
vers nous notre mission c'est de les
prendre et les emmener dans les
meilleures selon du monde y assouvir des
crs
ouais c'est vrai ça oui je m'en souviens
j'attends avec impatience on line
beauchamp on va y retourner
ok cool est-ce que tu as d un peu chaud
patate à louey je propose le procès par
un truc rigolo
yes un robot hualien j'adore il est
souvent derrière ce calme toi ils sont
un compagnon chien sur le petit robot
côté au travail
et en ville voir ce que fait t'on chien
à la maison deux solutions soit tu sors
ton téléphone et tu va piloter à
distance les cas du bon produit
tu vas pouvoir voir ce qu'il fait tu vas
pouvoir lui lancer des conquêtes
ayant aussi un mode autonome même si tu
n'y penses pas vraiment l'écart va jouer
avec ton chien ils s'ennuient aura plus
jamais de la vie c'est terminé sa savate
hommage se passe bien du rsa super on
est super content d'être à l'ifa avec
business france on rencontre beaucoup de
monde à super salon très intéressant de
distribuer aux chambres à deux partout
là donc super content génial génial
c'est ce que ce bien pour les cas ouais
ouais ça va on est en avance sur design
industriel ça avance et après tu devrais
commencer plein de l'année début de
l'année prochaine via la
commercialisation du courant de l'année
prochaine voilà et là on a des
distributeurs à l'international qui
viennent nous voir à montcenis à
l'attrait pour le produit donc
est-ce que tu coures aurélien rapport
devrait apprécier avec avril quand je
cours pour moi je cours personnellement
j'aime beaucoup et tout est souvent tu
fais un brassard sur sur le bras pour
vendre la musique pour savoir combien de
kilomètres tu as fait ouais et
honnêtement c'est que tu dois changer ta
musique ou des cas d'appel il était
comme ça tu topper du coup y'a des gars
de chez une partie qu'ils ont créé un
brassard où tu peux enlever le téléphone
avec un système d'aimants mais bon on
est à l'ifa le groupe de la technologie
ils ont intégré un capteur cardiaque y
dessus quand tu vois tu auras le couvrir
téléphone sonne et au lieu de galère et
un peu tu le défait et tu leur mets tu
me poses tu me prends pas la
ok mais il monte ça c'est pour la partie
ukrainienne est en réalité donc juste là
tu as un capteur cardiaque et du coup ça
te coûte vachement moins cher coûte
acheter une montre de tarés avec plein
de capteurs partout ça fait exactement
la même chose et c'est beaucoup moins
cher et je crois que c'est dans tous les
magasins de sport de france mais sa
surprise
tu réversion vélo ok si jamais tu cours
tu as tu fait peut-être fait vélo rien
s'il ya combien de temps je vous ai dit
tu marches dans l'essonne ce matin on
peut pas tout faire dans la vie pour ma
part moi j'habite à paris
il va pas se mentir il ya peut-être un
peu plus de pollution que dans d'autres
villes
si si petit peu c'est peut-être que des
fois on ferme un peu les routes et je
fais aussi de la moto du scooter avec
ses tirs et même du vélo
donc autant dire que quand je suis dans
la rue toute la journée du cheval pas
mal de choses près et auros bord on a
trouvé une start up qui a fait un masque
anti pollution taire les canons qui fit
un nombre de molécules incroyable mais
là c'est beaucoup trop compliqué pour
moi bonjour la scientifique je te
propose pendant parle avec ce qu'ils ont
fait nous on fait un masque anti
pollution pour les utilisateurs de roues
moto et runner on a développé un masque
qui permet de filtrer jusqu'au
nanomètres contre les particules très
très très très très petit tout en
conservant un confort et un designer de
l'utilisation on avait produit qui est
entièrement made in france
donc on est super fiers de le dire parce
que c'est vraiment produit de qualité et
première qu'on peut proposer aujourd'hui
et aujourd'hui on arrive en
commercialisation dans les magasins pour
octobre aux quelques quatre nouveaux
modèles quatre nouveaux modèles donc ça
c'est un produit pour enfin compte
gagner du pognon c'est ça un des points
de vie qui sont suivis via l'application
mobile qui nous permet de traquer en
temps réel et non connectés exactement
ça nous permet de savoir en temps réel
quand est ce qu'on va changer le filtre
et qu'elles sont le nom de sucre qu'on
n'a pas fumé et de points de vie qu'on a
gagné real ferait alors là il faut que
je gala mais j'ai fait remarquer dans le
salon comme ça donc là je peux courir
faire du vélo
l'enjeu n'est pas qui poker s'est imposé
dans les salons il ya toujours des
topics un peu trendy ya cinq ans alors
ils fassent les traits télévision etc
mais évidemment que de l'intelligence
artificielle des assistants vocaux on a
vu ce qui s'est passé google et amazon
qui est là et à la version française
la version française qui protège ton est
donné ok je vais te montrer une voix qui
s'appelle cynips ok cool à votre
incroyable l'objet snit ce que permet de
faire plein de choses mais avant que
j'adore mon petit kiff du salon de l'ifa
regarde ça
by sleep ce mec mieux qu'au fond
on va ton café tu veux mais bon voilà
seigneur c'est beaucoup alors le cas si
ça marche comme on peut
vous faites des communistes on recoupe
du peut connaître en version française
et ça j'y tiens énormément avec la
protection des données
j'ai pas envie qu'ils étaient connus
tout le temps voyager fait passer ma
commande en anglais parce que on est
quand même en allemagne et c'est un
salon international il est en réalité je
crois que c'est en français
en anglais en allemand et en japonais
regarde explique ce qu'on est chaud à je
ne sais pas dire autre chose
donc vous avez énormément de start-up
complètement différente
voilà déjà certifie ciel on est sur du
produit on est sûr de l'anim robots pour
animaux exactement du sport franches
sont les enfants
ouais et c'est un peu la beauté tu as
des nouvelles technologies c'est que tu
peux trouver de tout
mais en france sincèrement il ya des
startups canon on est très très très
content de pouvoir les accompagner sur
ces événements effectivement il ya
berlin et le fleuve à helsinki et le
wyoming qui est très connu et un peu
comme toi projette de retourner en
janvier aux crs de las vegas on va bien
s'organiser rahway on va s'organiser
alors du coup à vegas je serai combien
cette année c'est je crois que la
délégation avait traîné un peu en deçà
des chèques ou pas alors on va passer on
fait un énorme village france ok en fait
l'idée si tu veux c'est que les
personnes qui viennent voir les français
mais il faut qu'ils comprennent que la
boîte est française mais ce choix peut
regrouper
donc on sera un petit village de al et
160 go gateway et non en fait toutes les
régions de france pour y regrouper pour
faire un gros village france c'est
énorme ça va être génial comme ça on
jamais vu
on reparlera de saumade janvier ah bah
oui oui bon d'ici là on se reverra quand
même moi j'espère oui ça roule bon
écoute mince et maxime félicitations et
puis mon quotidien
oui mais toi vélo j'ai grossi ces sacs
ou
[Musique]